on s'est rendu compte que si on
calculait non pas seulement un rapport
de dépendance démographique avec
simplement des promus une proportion de
personnes âgées versus personne ne
voyageait mais qu'on est intégré dans la
productivité puis l'activité la
productivité c'est comme le rendement
d'un travail arras une machine ce
travail continue de se caresser comme le
en particulier niveau d'éducation le
fait que la population va aussi et puis
du pied dans le futur le fait que les
travailleurs âgés tendent à travailler
plus longtemps que dans le passé de la
retraite à 55 ans c'est fini
chez les personnes âgées de 55 ans et
plus les femmes ou si les jeunes
générations de femmes ont des
comportements synarchie travail
différent de celles du passé unis qui
sont plus hâtive mais tout se fait en
sorte que un nom de levier sans déplorer
a fait au lieu de créer 60 % +2 de
pression dit long sur la fiscalité ou
les régimes de pension pourrait avoir un
effet que de 10% pour savoir quand même
avoir un pied en effet sa c6 tout change
suffit de tendances récentes semaines
mais on peut aussi penser à avoir des
politiques soient l'immigration aux
politiques à sion ou encore d'accroître
niveau d'activité de la population pour
encore amoindries encore plus les
impacts négatifs du vieillissement sur
la fiscalité des pays une question de
passion